τι συμβίνε τους λέω να φωνάξουμε τον αδίλικοήταν ήταν ικίνιλικό με τον με τους γονίς
το με το πατέρ θα φωνάξειμε το ανδήρικο τα οπή και ιναν καντρέαπαραδέκτηκε ο ανδίλικος
ότι του άλλων παιδάκ που είχε της εξολική ήταναδελφος του ηλικρινά σκοτίνιασα όλα ηλικρινά είχαπέσε
από τα σύντεφα ήτα πολύ σοχαριστικό και το πιο σε ακαριστικό ήταν α πούμε του
πατέρα ότι αυτό συνύεα θυμάβε α κληρός αθέλεται άντρας αυτούς που ήταν στη επαρχία ξέρε
το πθό κάποι ρτόκαταλάβει ότι ς κληρός άντρας αι προσπαθοα του δογο και όταν κατάλαβε
ηλεκρινά λιποθίμησε τω άνθρωπος ήταν πολύ πολύ υπολύ σιοχαριστικόν αυτό και ακόματο ου έχουν παράσιμε
παλλά χρονια και ακόματα έχω τό το μυαλό μου πολύ τακτικά αυτό το τινικόνν και
πάνταθα τεέχο στο μυαλό μουυ μαζί μου και ομου λέει όπου ατέρας φαντάσου ήστερα που
δέκαδεκαβένται χρόνια ή στην υπόληπι τους τη ζωή ότι θα ότε θα ξέρει ου να
αυτοί γίνει με τον ανάλοήταν παιδιά τοτέ και τώρα δεν έχουν γίνει οι άντρες φαντάζομε
φαντάστται πωςν δύσκολο είναι αυτό το πράγμα ήταν πολύσιοχαριστικό αυτόσο σχ να βρισκι υπηρέι ας
για αλάξουμεθέμα κυπριόπουλά μέσα σε αυτά τα αρχία που εντοποιζεται σε σπίτια τόμα που συλάμβάνεται
να αλλάξεοείναι θύλικο θέμα πραγματή δεν δεν υπάρχει ευτυχώς είναι υπάρχει ανευτύχημα ότι δεν έχου
διαδοθή τέτοιον λικών για νέες τη διάθεση της εμπορία α θέλετα τς αγοράς της διακίνησης
τετοιοηλικού υπάρχουν περιπτώσεις ότι στην κύπρο ναι το παίρνει να μαθητής από την προλεφιλήτου